he has a night check but it is it  doesn't help it's you can't stop  Checkmate or losing your queen here yep  Checkmate is coming one way or the other  the evaluation bar is shot all the way  up no defense 10 seconds on the clock  he throws in one last desperate check  this Knight can just safely be captured  and maybe another check with the black  queen but and you can block with a queen  here yeah simple way there we go Magnus  swapping the Queens off extra night  extra Pawn  he's going to win the tournament wow and  there it is it's over ordinary guys he  resigns facing an impossible world  number one Magnus Carlsen with a slight  smile there he is the winner of the  Julius bear generation cop he's been  fantastic this tournament only lost well  two games one of them was two arms  Neiman away from Magnus Carlsen watch a  performance he has reached  2900 on the tour rage